good morning John it's Friday so after
the general confusion and jet lag and
delicacies and all the tiny yet somehow
overwhelming differences of London my
world is exploding we went to Dublin
where I was finally and truly hit with
that same tired old realization that all
Americans have upon traveling to Europe
dang this place is old but also like new
like super new this sense of extreme
juxtaposition old right across the river
from new old boat new bridge old stairs
new stairs old security system new
security system old obelisk new obelisk
it seemed to me like two categories with
a fine line between them and I know to
some people that will make me seem like
some kind of barbarian but if you were
raised to the place where the oldest
building was built in the 1950s you
might lack some historical perspective
too but then as we traveled around
popping into every single book shop to
see if they'd had The Fault in Our Stars
what were you just doing John Dublin
started to teach us about itself a
cathedral that took so long to construct
that Romanesque arches sit right next to
Gothic arches to architectural styles as
different and separated by as many years
as this building and this one with a
crypt underneath it predating both of
those architectural styles in fact the
oldest structure in Dublin though with
some decidedly new uses in addition to
having a museum there's also a gift shop
a coffee shop and some toilets but of
course Dublin's history reaches back a
lot further than that as we learned at
table linea a celebration of Dublin's
founding as a Viking colony which I
mentioned mostly so that I can show you
this Viking pooping
but then a little more robustly I peeked
into Ireland's very long history at the
National Museum of Archaeology and
suddenly this intense cultural
continuity came into a weird sort of
focus for me with these axe heads being
carved 5,800 years before these brooches
were molded 2 centuries before Strongbow
died 400 years before this library was
founded 300 years before this primitive
means of wired communication was
invented 1600 years before this
fossilized bog mummy died 400 years
before these other toubab mummies died
almost 2,000 years before this cat
chased this rat into a pipe organ
Christchurch Cathedral where they both
together were also mummified 300 years
before this gutter was installed 14
years before this event was crazy and
more than 1200 years before the first
Viking moved on iron
we only have a concept of self because
of our ability to symbolically recall
our past and stitch together a story of
who we are in many ways we are never the
same physically or psychologically from
instant to instant
it's that continuity that makes us us
that same thing can be said of a place
or of a culture or even of a species yes
at any given moment Dublin is a
different city than it was at the moment
before but while it at first looked like
a city of juxtaposition it became a
continuum a continuum that was respected
and honored and that reached back tens
of thousands of years and then I felt
like I was a part of without that
consciousness of our past which is very
easy not to have for those of us who
live in towns that have barely existed
for a hundred years it's easy to forget
that we're not only living in this
particular instant but as part of a
continuum thousands or tens of thousands
or even millions of years old and
without that perspective I think we
might be a little bit culturally stunted
so basically what I'm saying is watch
crash course world history and Vikings
pooped too
John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]